History Channel's hit reality television
show Pawn Stars has been on the air for
ten years and it's certainly been an
eventful decade the show has had its
fair share of heartfelt moments and
tense situations here are the most
unforgettable moments in Pawn Stars
history in one of the most iconic
moments from the first season Rick big
Hoss and Chumlee all worked together to
pull a fast one on the old man they
arranged to have his beloved 1966
Chrysler Imperial towed from the gold
and Silver's back lot to be given a full
restoration there's a twist they do so
in secret so when the old man comes into
the store asking where his car is Rick
tells his father that they finally sold
the thing hey Corey what Rick where's my
damn Imperial sold it you what I thought
it was just gonna sit there and rot so
we sold it for a thousand bucks after
the old man threatens to unleash the
wrath of God Chumlee goes even further
informing the old man that this
fictional buyer was planning on turning
the rare classic into a lowrider with
hydraulics and a cheetah skin interior
the old man storms off after cursing at
his son and grandson a few weeks later
the car's finished and Rick brings the
old man to the back lot to reveal the
gift for his 50th wedding anniversary
the old man loves his newly restored car
and even calls it a work of art watching
the old man go from furious to ecstatic
makes this one of the best moments of
the show's entire run in the sixth
season episode say it ain't so a
customer comes into the store with a
book signed by baseball player Shoeless
Joe Jackson not only was Jackson a
legendary baseball player he was
illiterate so his signature is
incredibly rare naturally Rick asks for
any documentation that may support the
customers story to his surprise the
customer produces a letter of
authentication and Rick decides to buy
the book on the spot for $13,000 before
the customer can change his mind and
sell it somewhere else
afterwards Rick brings in an
Authenticator to see if the signature is
legitimate since he hadn't heard of the
Authenticator who signed the customer's
letter
unfortunately the expert reports that
the signature is likely fake Rick
decides to send the book off to yet
another Authenticator but is given a
laundry list of reasons to be confident
that the signature is a fake all in all
Rick learns about 13 thousand reasons to
double-check that a rare object
is actually rare during the season 1
episode Secret Santa Chumlee enters the
pawn shop in a jolly mood with a Santa
outfit to match complementing his outfit
is a bushy white beard in a sack full of
presents Cory quickly tells Chumlee that
the role of Santa has already been taken
for the day murder Christmas tree won't
Chumbley comes back to work later
dressed as an elf eliciting laughs from
the elder Harrisons at the end of the
day the cast of Pawn Stars all exchange
gifts as part of a Secret Santa
arrangement everyone's gifts are small
except for Rick's present - Chumlee when
he first lays eyes on the watch Rick
Adam Chumlee seems completely shocked
the gesture from Rick demonstrates how
close the group is and how they really
do care for each other
in the first season episode time
machines a man brings in a flintlock
pistol he had bought at a gun show
seeing the potential for an interesting
piece of history at his store Corey
calls in an expert in vintage firearms
to appraise the value of the gun the
expert relays that if the gun is
authentic it could fetch a price upwards
of $2,500 unfortunately however the gun
is just a modern recast of an old design
that's only worth about $75 outside the
store the customer says my wife was
pissed when I bought this gun now she's
really gonna kill me
[Music]
being tricked into buying something fake
for a grossly inflated price is a
horrible situation to find oneself in
finding out on national television is
even worse in celebration of Halloween
during the season 4 episode Rick or
Treat the employees at the gold and
silver decide to compete in a costume
contest with a prize of $100 for the
best costume the results aren't exactly
inspiring Corey does the bare minimum
putting on a novelty headband that makes
it look like someone stabbed through his
skull with a knife no one can guess that
rick has dressed up as dr. evil from the
Austin Powers films Chumlee is dressed
up as the then teen heartthrob Justin
Bieber while the old man is dressed up
as rooster cogburn from True Grit
the bickering all ends when Antwon the
security guard walks up to the counter
dressed as a giant baby binky and all
this immediately Nets him the $100 with
the snickering approval of the Harrisons
and Chumlee the season 5 episode Corey's
big play features a customer selling a
set of artifacts from an Arizona prison
carrying a couple of balls and chains
from Yuma prison in an antique Wells
Fargo strongbox the customer hopes to
leave the store with $2,000 upon closer
inspection the balls have the prison
name embossed on them and the chains
appeared to have been electrically
welded making both sets of items in
authentic recreations
however the strongbox passes Rick's
inspections so he begins negotiations at
$400 eventually settling at 450 dollars
Rick secures the Wells Fargo box to
determine the box's value Rick brings in
a museum administrator to appraise the
box but when it is revealed that the box
is a fake the old man chides Rick saying
he suspected the box was fake the entire
time why'd he let Rick make such a big
mistake I didn't want to bust your
bubble
what so you relevee spend the money
instead now I can holler at you after
spending almost a decade on television
Richard old man Harrison passed away in
June 2018 at the age of 77 as a tribute
to his memory the final episode of
season 15 was made into an hour-long
special showcasing the best of the old
man in the special Rick reminisce about
his dad between clips showing just how
much the old man cared of
his family his business and his passions
the episode is nostalgic and intimate
allowing the audience to feel included
in the lives of these people they have
spent the last nine years watching the
highlighted clips of the old man show
him at his best sometimes when he was
happiest other times when he would get
angry with the other employees at the
gold and silver but every scene showed
off his no-nonsense approach to dealing
with others no matter who he was dealing
with the old man would never mince words
and would always play fair making him
one of the most beloved cast members on
the show when a seller named Phil visits
the shop looking to sell his 32 Lincoln
roadster in the season four episode by
the book it isn't exactly hard to get
Rick and the old man to jump out from
behind the pawn shop counter bargaining
and settling on an agreeable price is
another story however Phil wants
$100,000 a price Rick is skeptical about
considering the vehicle isn't in prime
condition according to Rick a 32 Lincoln
roadster can be sold for about one
hundred and seventy thousand dollars in
mint condition but Phil's car has some
wear and tear that diminishes the value
at first it seems like Phil will refuse
to budge on anything lower than $100,000
but then he tells Rick he's willing to
sell the car for $95,000 in gold while
legally Rick can't exchange the old car
for gold Rick can give Phil $95,000 and
then he can then turn around and buy
$95,000 worth the gold from the shop the
32 Lincoln roadster isn't just one of
Rick's most expensive purchases it's one
of the most unique ways anyone on the
show has named their price
I think I'll bury the gold somewhere
where nobody can get it
in the season four episode appropriately
titled face the music Chumlee strikes a
bargain for $1500 with a customer over
what appears to be an authentic Gibson
mandolin
however the bargain was struck before an
expert could be brought in to assess the
instrument big mistake once the expert
is brought in to evaluate the mandolin
it's not only revealed to be a fake but
an obvious one at that in the words of
the expert himself yeah this is fake as
hell man this is I just paid $1,500 for
that now Shh so what exactly gave the
replica way for starters the decal was
cut out with scissors and the G and
Gibson doesn't match the official
branding to make matters worse the
instruments finish appears to be plastic
whereas a genuine Gibson would use
lacquer this long list of issues along
with a few other giveaways makes it a
gut punch for poor Chumlee when he has
to tell Rick and the old man that he
blew $1500 on a bad knockoff so how
exactly is Chumlee supposed to get back
that money in a fitting punishment he's
forced to play the fake mandolin outside
the shop for tips to earn back the loss
of his investment hopefully Chumlee can
play the mandolin as well as that seller
played him in the season 2 episode hell
week corey and chumlee struggled to move
a heavy statue across the store as the
two huff and puff the old man and Rick
take notice and give them grief when
their physical abilities are called into
question Corey asserts that he could
beat Chumlee in any sort of competition
Rick challenges Corey and Chumlee to
compete in an obstacle course with the
stipulation that the loser will have to
buy lunch for a week
the obstacle course consists of a tire
stepping station a jumping jack station
and a jump rope station in the end Corey
ends up winning but after the duo's
clumsy performance neither manages to
impress Rick or the old man watching
these two turkeys run this course is
going to be like watching a grizzly bear
ice skate it ain't gonna be pretty
still watching Corey and Chumlee get
competitive with each other is a rare
sight that makes this episode one of the
most enjoyable in the second season
episode flight of the Chum a customer
visits the gold and silver with a statue
of Perseus and Pegasus made by Emil
Picoult
Rick is familiar with Buchholz work and
he knows that his statues are highly
collectible and worth
thousands of dollars so he gives the
customers item a thorough look
however Rick immediately become
suspicious when he finds markings on the
statue that do not match the period it
was supposedly produced in he then finds
markings engraved on the statue showing
that it was made in the United States
since the artist is French this confirms
that the statue is a reproduction at the
suggestion that the statue may not be
entirely authentic the customer gets
angry with Rick I don't care what you
say I don't care what you tell me but I
know you fool as the tension mounts the
pawnshop security guard Antoine begins
walking toward the customer in case an
intervention is needed however he is
waved off by Rick in the end the old man
diffuses the situation by firmly
explaining that they are not interested
in buying the statue which brings the
memorable interaction to a close check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you